- Rube Foster starts
the Negro National League in 1920.
- When the league started,
there were eight teams.
- The beauty of starting
a baseball league during that period,
gave an opportunity for men
of color to play baseball,
where there was no opportunity
in the white major leagues.
The challenges that Andrew "Rube" Foster
had in 1920 when he started
the Negro National League
was economic stability,
a solid league schedule
and the availability of ballparks.
- When we look at the Negro leagues
in comparison to the major leagues,
talent? No difference.
But the major leagues had more money,
and they had their own stadiums.
That's really the one
fundamental difference
between the two leagues.
- Black owners, for the most part,
they didn't own their own stadiums.
They had to rent stadiums
from white teams.
That cut into profits.
So they spent a lot of time on the road.
They were barnstorming constantly.
- You have to have your own bus.
You can't ride the train
during the era of segregated.
- They can't stay in hotels.
- Quite a few of them spent their time
sleeping on their bus.
- They can't eat at restaurants.
- Major league ballplayers
made between six and
seven times the amount
that the average Negro
league ballplayer made.
- Racism is real in the United States.
And so it's not different
for baseball players,
even if they are great at what they do.
We can see gaps in coverage,
and a lot of that is because the racism
that they endured from the white press
that didn't feel that what they were doing
on segregated ball fields was valuable.
- When you say "Negro leagues,"
it actually encompassed many leagues.
You had a Southern League.
You had the Eastern Colored League.
You had the Negro American League.
- The competing leagues
caused significant problems
for each other, because quite honestly,
it came down to market share.
Rube Foster decided he
wanted to expand to the East.
Well, that was gonna infringe upon
the other major Black clubs in the East.
So they formed their own league.
- In 1924,
the first Colored World Series.
- The Kansas City Monarchs and Hilldale,
out of the Eastern Colored League,
they decided they were
gonna play each other.
- Kansas City Monarchs won that series
against Ed Bolden's Hilldale Club.
It started a new wave of
popularity and acceptance.
- [Reporter:] The tremendous crowds,
which you see gathered outside,
are due to the greatest crash
in the history
[Car horn honking]
of the New York Stock Exchange.
- When we have an economic setback
like the Great Depression,
white America catches a cold.
Black America catches pneumonia.
- A lot of Black people
were out of work. They just
couldn't support the game,
and that was the majority
of their fanbase.
- Rube Foster was on
league business in 1925
in Indianapolis when he
was exposed to a gas leak
inside of his hotel room.
Never quite the same; likely
suffered brain damage.
As a result, was subject
to fits of violent outrage,
forcing his family to
institutionalize him,
where three years later,
he dies of a heart attack.
Negro leagues had lost
its spiritual leader.
- In 1931, the Negro
National League folded.
- The death of Rube Foster
devastated the Negro National League.
But then you couple that
with the Great Depression,
and it had virtually no
shot to continue to operate.
- Even though the Negro
National League ended,
there's always somebody else to be able
to pick up that mantle.
- Gus Greenlee
was the Rube Foster of the 1930s.
- Gus Greenlee would
revive the Negro Leagues.
- They called him Big Red.
Had two brothers became a doctor,
but he chose the street life.
- Gus Greenlee was a numbers runner.
He, before that, was a rum runner.
- He was also an owner of a nightclub.
When the only bank in Pittsburgh fell
because of the Depression,
Gus Greenlee became the
banker of the Black community.
This man was brilliant.
- He got into baseball when some members
of the Pittsburgh Crawfords team
came into his club that he owned in 1930
and asked him to invest in their team.
They were a semi-pro
sandlot team at the time
and, you know, were facing
financial challenges
like so many independent Black clubs did.
So he purchases the
team, puts them on salary
and then kinda sets out to become
the king of Black baseball
in the Pittsburgh area.
He starts the second Negro
National League in late 1932.
They play their first season in 1933.
- And really at that point,
take the Negro leagues to its apex,
creating the vaunted
East-West All-Star Game,
debuting the same year
as Major League Baseball's All-Star Game.
- We see in the 1940s
that they were drawing
more fans at this Black All-Star Game
than Major League Baseball was.
This was the biggest sporting
event in Black America.
- December 7, 1941, a date
which will live in infamy.
- World War II adversely
impacted both leagues,
but it didn't hurt the
Negro Leagues quite as bad
as it hurt Major League Baseball.
The Negro leagues certainly
had its fair share
of athletes who served,
but the superstar players
from the Negro leagues were too old,
where that young major league
stars got called into service,
Major League Baseball
literally had to shut down.
But the Negro leagues were still going,
and white fans came over to
watch Negro leagues baseball.
- Defense hiring means
that a lot of Black people
who'd been out of work for
so long get well-paying jobs.
Now they have extra money,
not just to make ends meet,
but to actually come to games.
Black teams have more money
because more fans are coming to games.
- It was the greatest
experience of the week.
- Everybody's dressed up.
- Women would bring fried
chicken, pass a basket
of home-baked bread around.
An awesome experience,
and we hadn't even got
to the ballgame yet.
- We're talking about some of
the greatest baseball players
to ever put on a baseball uniform.
- You can drop names all day
long, like Roy Campanella.
- Cool Papa Bell the fastest guy to play.
- Monte Irvin.
- Then you add Oscar Charleston.
- Bullet Rogan gonna hit a home run
and strike out 15 or 16.
- Buck Leonard.
- Piper Davis.
- Guess who's the greatest home run hitter
that ever played the game?
Josh Gibson.
- Everybody wanted to see Josh Gibson.
The legendary Satchel Paige.
- Satchel Paige
could do a doubleheader by himself.
- Satchel was so big, when
the Monarchs went out to play,
if Satchel didn't pitch,
the people felt like,
"We want our money back."
- When Black servicemen came
back home to this country,
they still were subjected
to a lot of the things
that were going on in this
country before they left.
- America had to wake up to the fact
that we were a segregated
and racist country,
and maybe it was time to
integrate our national pastime.